TOP SECRET CLEARANCES, SEAN.
>> Sean: ED HENRY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT.
ED, AS ALWAYS WE APPRECIATE
IT JOINING US WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
ANTHONY THE MOOCH SCARAMUCCI
AND GERALDO RIVERA.
THE MEDIA -- THEY WERE SO
CRUEL TO HER AS IT RELATES
TO SHE IS DATING SOMEBODY.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: IT'S NONE OF THEIR
BUSINESS NUMBER ONE OH SHE
ADMITS SHE TOLD A WHITE LIE.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD LOVE TO
DO THE INTERVIEW.
IT'S A NICE WAY OF SAYING
NO.
OR YOU LOOK -- YOU LOOK
GREAT WHEN YOU DON'T THINK
THE PERSON LOOKS GREAT.
>> TELL ME A PERSON IN THE
WORLD WHO HASN'T TOLD A
WHITE LIE AND I WILL
IDENTIFY THE BIGGEST LIAR IN
THE ROOM, SEAN.
THAT'S THE RIDICULOUS
STATEMENT.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA LIES
EVERY DAY.
>> YEAH.
BUT THEY LIKE ROLLING PEOPLE
LIKE HOPE IN BROKEN GLASS TO
SEE IF SHE WILL BREAK.
SHE IS MADE OUT OF STEEL
OBVIOUSLY SHE WON'T BREAK.
SHE IS A WONDERFUL PERSON.
I WILL TELL YOU SHE IS THE
ONE OF THE MOST LEAST
MILITIA PEOPLE I EVER MET IN
MY LIFE.
SHE IS DEDICATED.
SHE IS DHARMING, SHE IS
THOUGHTFUL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, SHE
GOING TO HAVE AN
UNBELIEVABLE CAREER, SEAN.
>> Sean: SHE IS 29 AND HAS
UNBELIEVABLE CAREER.
>> HOPE, IF YOU ARE WATCHING
MY AGENT HAS CALLED ME AND
SAID PLEASE, LET ME
REPRESENT HOPE HICKS.
I WILL GIVE HER A CALL.
>> Sean: SHE CAN WORK AT THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
>> ANYTHING YOU WANT.
ALL STAR HOLLYWOOD AGENT.
MY POINT IS THAT THIS WOMAN
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR ABOVE
EVERYTHING ELSE.
YOU ARE ENTREPRENEUR AS YOU
KNOW YOU BUILT THIS FROM
NOTHING.
LOOK WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID
STARTING WITH HER AND COREY
LEWANDOWSKI.
AND HIS CHILDREN TO WHERE IS
HE TODAY.
SHE DESERVES ALL THE RESPECT
AND LOVE AND SUPPORT AND
KINDNESS THAT YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
>> Sean: GERALDO, I SAW FROM
THE BEGINNING IT WAS HER AND
COREY AND SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
LOOK, PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
WEAR OUT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND SHE HUNG THE WHOLE TIME,
WAS THERE THE WHOLE TIME.
AND WHAT'S SO UNBELIEVABLE
TO ME, GERALDO, DID YOU EVER
LIKE -- YOU DON'T WANT TO
TELL SOMEBODY WE ARE NEVER
GIVING YOU THE INTERVIEW.
WE WILL TRY.
ISN'T THAT WHAT A WHITE LIE
IS?
AND THE MEDIA HAS BLOWN THAT
UP INTO SOMETHING THAT IT
NEVER WAS OR GETTING INTO A
PERSONAL LIFE AND CAMERAS
ARE FOLLOWING HER TO HER
APARTMENT, IN HER TAXICAB.
IT'S PRETTY DESPICABLE HOW
THEY HAVE TREATED HER.
>> THEY CUT HER UP LIKE
MUGGERS, SEAN.
NOBODY IS INDISPENSIBLE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE EXCEPT FOR
THE PRESIDENT WITH THE
POSSIBLE EXCEPTION OF THE
CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN KELLY,
GENERAL JOHN KELLY.
BUT HOPE HICKS COMES AS
CLOSE AS THEY DO
CLOSE AS THEY COME.
SHE WAS A TRUSTED LOYAL
FRIEND.
YOU AND I KNOW ABOUT LOYALTY
AND FRIENDSHIP AND TRUST.
THE PRESIDENT COULD TRUST
HER.
HE HAS TRUSTED HER FOR THREE
YEARS.
SHE HAS TAKEN THIS -- FROM
THE CANDIDATE, THE LONG SHOT
CANDIDATE, THE BUCKAROO, THE
WILD MAVERICK, HELPED MOLD
HIM INTO THE CANDIDATE THAT
HE BECAME TO WIN THE
PRESIDENCY AND THEN IN THE
FIRST YEAR IN OFFICE SHE HAS
BEEN A KEY AIDE.
SHE HAS BEEN BY HIS SIDE.
BUT SHE HAS BEEN WHITTLED
DOWN, SHE HAS BEEN WORN
DOWN.
AND I THINK THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND
HOW THEY DEALT WITH HER AND
HOW THEY SLANDERED HER, THAT
COMING ON THE HEELS, MOOCH
MENTIONED THE WHOLE ROB
PORTER THING.
YOU KNOW, SHE HAS HAD A LOT.
SHE HELPED DRAFT THAT
STATEMENT ON AIR FORCE ONE
ABOUT THE DONALD TRUMP JR.
MEETING AT TRUMP TOWER.
SHE HAS GONE THROUGH A LOT.
SHE IS VERY YOUNG.
SHE HAS BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE.
SHE HAS BEEN VERY LOYAL.
SHE WILL BE SORELY MISSED.
I LA MINT THIS.
THIS IS BAD NEWS.
YOU KNOW, MERCEDES SCHLAPP.
>> WE KNOW HER.
SHE WAS WITH FOX NEWS FOR
MANY YEARS.
SHE IS THE WHITE HOUSE
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS.
SHE WOULD BE A REPLACEMENT
THAT I COULD ENDORSE.
I THINK THERE IS NO DOUBT
THAT HOPE HICKS WILL BE
MISSED, SEAN.
>> Sean: ANTHONY, I AGREE IN
THE SENSE THAT SHE'LL BE
MISSED GERALDO IS RIGHT IT'S
THE PRESIDENT.
>> PENCE IS WAY MORE
ININCIDENCE CYBIL THAN CHIEF
OF STAFF KELLY.
THE OTHER THING IS THESE
PEOPLE SHOULD START
APPOINTING PEOPLE LIKE RIC
GRENELL AND START DOING THE
JOB.
>> Sean: ACROSS THE BOARD BY
THE WAY.
I AGREE WITH YOU ON GRENELL.
>> THIS IS THE GERMAN
COUNTRY, THE THIRD OR FOURTH
LARGEST ECONOMY.
BY DON'T WE HAVE AN
AMBASSADOR THERE?
>> Sean: I THINK WE SEND
HERALD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I GOT ANOTHER
AMBASSADORSHIP FOR GERALDO.
I'M GOING TO SEND YOU WHERE
REINCE PRIEBUS WANTED TO
SEND ME ANTARCTICA.
>> GOOD ONE.
>> SO FAR WE ARE DOING OKAY
WITH THE PENGUINS.
>> Sean: I THINK HERALD IT
WOULD
GEULD
GERAD
GERALDOWOULD DO GOOD IN AN ARTIC
GERALDOWOULD DO GOOD IN AN ARTIA
GERALDOWOULD DO GOOD IN AN ARTI.
HE WOULD HAVE A POLICE
SIREN.
>> PUERTO RICANS DON'T DO
WELL IN ANTARCTICA.
>> HOPE IS GOING TO DO WELL.
>> THE THING ABOUT HOPE
HICKS, WE CAN'T OVERLOOK THE
FACT THAT SHE WAS REMARKABLE
FOR HER AGE.
SHE WAS A STEADY PRESENCE.
AND I DON'T KNOW, YOU KNOW,
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR OTHER
REPORTERS, BUT SHE WAS MY
LIFELINE TO THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN I NEEDED TO SPEAK TO
THE PRESIDENT OR I WANTED TO
BE WITH THE PRESIDENT LIKE
THE MAR-A-LAGO MEETING JUST
A WEEK AND A HALF AGO.
>> Sean: SHE WAS EVERYONE'S
LIFELINE.
>> SHE WAS EVERYONE'S
>> Sean: THERE IS HOPE WITH
FOUR PHONES AND THAT'S HOW